traveling through canadian airports like
here in montreal is tough enough right
now not everyone's keen to see coveted
testing return
not at the moment no
it just confuses things and holds things
up
it wasn't hard to find people against
the idea but there are those who aren't
disappointed i think it's good because
it is back
when covent testing returns next week
for people traveling by air it won't be
at the airport travelers coming back on
international flights will be able to go
to a testing facility a pharmacy or even
do it virtually with a monitored
self-swap now for people who qualify as
fully vaccinated only some will have to
be tested they'll be picked at random
and have until the end of the next
calendar day people who aren't
vaccinated will have to be tested in
fact twice they have to do 14 days of
quarantine and tests on day one and day
eight
moving the testing out of airports the
federal transport minister says is to
try to make things run more smoothly he
says the government's trying to make
airports work better right now not worse
we recognize that testing at airports
what was adding a layer of congestion
now experts we spoke to question how
effective this program will be it's not
going to prevent covid from entering the
country the government says that's not
the point that is to be able to track
how much covet is coming in and monitor
for new variants
nothing wrong with testing and getting
genome sequencing on people returning to
find out you know is a a new variant or
sub-variant starting to come into canada
more often it's probably not going to
control the numbers but knowing that
information can be potentially useful to
public health
as for how people will be selected for
testing that'll be done through the
arrivedcan app people will make their
customs declaration and then be notified
by email they've been chosen as for how
many people will be tested the
government says it's about five percent
of people returning to canada